j'ai votre discrétion vous aviez ici des
vêtements confortables savent-ils que je suis noir aujourd'hui je
ne vous ai jamais vu comme ça avant m'a amené la
famille prenez-le des cafards alors vous
venez en ville
ouais il y a un week-end
puis-je voir votre licence s'il vous plaît  elle ne conduisait pas
je n'ai pas demandé qui conduisait j'ai demandé à
voir sa carte d'identité depuis combien de temps cela dure
nous avons embauché Georgina et Walter pour aider à
prendre soin de mon panner ils ne pouvaient pas
supporter de le laisser partir ton
odeur m'inquiétait  mitrailleur je vais démissionner elle s'occupe
de cet ami ce n'est rien
je vais bien en fait apparemment tout un
tas d'autres Anissa découvre cool
tu n'as pas peur c'est mec saviez-vous
frère argent ouais désolé mec Rosie vas-
y toi  aller skier je ne sais pas ce que ça dit
merci à la pour attendre attends
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci plus tard
oui merci mec si tu laisses les gens
entrer
[Musique]
en moi